les voyages forment la jeunesse lorsque
cette jeunesse est réunionnaise et
qu'elle s'envole pour mieux comprendre
d'où viennent ses racines la formation
compte double c'est leur propre histoire
qu'ils vont découvrir
ouvrir pour préparer leur
identité de Réunionnais adulte de demain
les déplacements et on le fait avec les
partenaires les communes les
collectivités le conseil général en
particulier ici parce que lorsqu'un
élève part 15 jours dans un autre pays
ou un autre lieu qu'il n'est pas il
n'est pas habitué il apprend
avoir ce que d'autres personnes vivent
au quotidien le Conseil général finance
le séjour de six groupes de collégiens à
Madagascar en Bretagne au Mozambique en
Chine et en Inde à une condition qu'il
retranscrivent sur le papier leur
parcours leur ressenti leur découverte
durant leur périple ce carnet de voyage
sera le miroir de leurs émotions
ces 16 élèves et ces quatre professeurs
du collège de Montgaillard sont les
premiers à se lancer dans l'aventure la
veille du décollage en cours de cuisine
la destination et sur toutes les lèvres
et se retrouvent même dans la marmite
même si le menu du dernier repas à la
SEGPA est alsacien une petite touche de
massalé cette invitée dans la recette
des spetsley
alors en a vous allez voir aussi
les gens goûtés comme comme vous dans la
main
Patrice bannereau fait partie des quatre
accompagnants l'Inde c'est comme son
deuxième pays le professeur y a
travaillé comme cuisinier il y a une
vingtaine d'années pendant ces 15
prochains jours il souhaite que ses
élèves découvrent ce qu'il a passionné à
l'époque les échanges culinaires la
préparation d'un repas avec les écoliers
de bottes Gaïa est au programme du 6e
jour c'est important bon c'est difficile
forcément pour eux de s'imaginer comment
comment ça va comment ça va se passer
ils pourront rencontrer des jeunes de
leur âge et c'est important pour eux
c'est peut-être la partie la plus
importante du voyage après les premiers
jours intenses de découverte sur les
rives du Gange le groupe arrive
acclimaté dans l'état du billard à
botgaia déjà plus de 1000 km parcourus
sur le territoire indien la veille du
repas fatiati et zayette participent aux
préparatifs la logistique doit être
imparable avec ses 250 enfants et sa
cinquantaine d'invités l'école
associative de Jeanne Perret a
transformé le repas commun en
pique-nique géant les grains le riz les
épices se pèsent en dizaines de kilos
pomme de terre
c'est tout non le lendemain la surprise
n'est pas que dans la marmite elle est
aussi dans la beauté du site donc
gâchoiri célèbre pour ses grottes
bouddhistes les enfants ont fait
connaissance la veille et tout
naturellement des affinités se sont
créés
pendant que le groupe profite de la vue
des hauteurs Patrice Bannerot s'est
rapprochée de la cuisine éphémère au
menu poulet massala grand format toutes
sortes de poules d'épices Aldi donc ça
c'est le ça c'est le safran le curcuma
en fait ça fait à peu près une
demi-heure qui fait chauffer les oignons
le poulet dans la dans la sauce
poulet pour 300 300 personnes ah là ça
s'agit un petit peu ils ont ils sont
obligés de se dépêcher un petit peu
parce que il y a déjà le riz et le dalle
sur la table un repas deux jours de
partage avec les enfants après lesquels
il a été bien difficile de se dire au
revoir
les émotions fortes retranscrites à
chaud dans le carnet de voyage dès le
retour à l'hôtel la mémoire à cet âge là
pour les enfants comme ils sont fatigués
c'est assez volatil donc tout de suite
il faut prendre des petites notes et
ensuite on prend du temps comme là on
est au calme on écrit et on les aide à
faire des résumés je me souviens pas
compte quand j'écris ça je saurais que
tout le monde est pleurer pour
pour les orphelin
et voilà ça c'était un moment fort
j'allais pleurer mais je me suis fait je
me suis retenue oui c'était de l'esprit
mais
j'ai vécu plein de choses
mais pour l'heure les élèves restent des
enfants loin de leurs parents à tour de
rôle ils peuvent profiter des rares
moyens de communication fonctionnelle
pour prendre des nouvelles
et toi
sur facebook
bisous les kilomètres s'accumulent au
compteur et un autre temps fort du
séjour se dessine depuis le bus lune des
sept merveilles du monde quand j'avais
regardé un film
dans un film j'étais c'est vraiment un
très très jolie et j'avais dit dans ma
tête je voudrais bien aller en Inde et
découvrir le Taj Mahal
c'est vraiment magnifique la vue
une merveille architecturale dont la
caméra ne peut s'approcher le mausolée
de marbre construit au 17e siècle et
protégé des prises de vue sauf exception
bollywoodienne les films
ça sent d'amour et Taj Mahal c'est
semoule d'amour après une demi-journée
de visite joelia ne se lasse pas de
l'histoire de Shah Hasan et mountasmaal
c'était quand quand elle était morte la
femme du
roi
sa femme elle est morte quand elle a mis
au monde son 14e fille dans la Bourhan
sur cette rive de la rivière Yamuna loin
de l'effervescence du centre d'Agra land
rural a elle aussi vu sur le Taj Mahal
le guide en profite pour s'attarder sur
un combustible encore utilisé en Inde la
galette de bouse
de beauflot et boule de graisse et on
fait galette comme ça les habitants
le chauffage le galette la nuit tombe et
les cultivateurs sont toujours au
travail Philippe Miranville fatiati et
Sylvina tentent un brin de causette
les élèves commencent à le comprendre
l'Inde est un pays de contraste dixième
jour de périple direction la capitale du
Rajasthan
comment
désolé maman
c'est l'heure pour les professeurs de
s'accorder un moment de détente créative
mais l'heure de la négociation n'est
jamais bien loin
à quelques mètres de là un autre concert
est en bonne voie
un rêve bleu au pays des Maradja le
Rajasthan c'est pour beaucoup la carte
postale de l'Inde
les palais qui appartiennent à
l'histoire quoi habite avec la modernité
des commerces dans ce bazar de Jay pour
les pâtisseries traditionnelles font
face au vendeur de technologie
il est bon
face aux vitrines de téléphone portable
les vaches rumines imperturbable après
10 jours d'expérience en négociation
Quentin ne tombe plus dans certains
pièges
une autre affaire est tout de même
conclue quelques minutes plus tard
cette baffe le fait son effet il lui en
coûtera 800 roupies soit environ 5 euros
dernier achat du dimanche le jour des
cerfs-volants tant qu'il restera un peu
de lumière dans le ciel il continueront
à tournoyer les trois quarts du séjour
sont déjà écoulés sur les marches du
palais de Jaipur cette petite session
carnet de voyage permet de prendre du
recul
il y a beaucoup de gens dans la rue des
voitures passent en même temps que les
gens aussi qui a beaucoup de pauvres
quand j'étais anaïeu je ne savais même
pas
qui a quelque part les gens peuvent
souffrir demander quelque chose à manger
de l'argent en recul nécessaire avant
l'arrivée dans la capitale dans
l'effervescence de délit les collégiens
retrouvent les klaxons mais les richo
ont laissé place aux véhicules privés de
plus en plus nombreux dans les
embouteillages nous sommes
janvier
1948 il a été tué à Delhi surtout il a
joué à autre important pour avoir
l'indépendance et surtout son
philosophie des noms violences pourquoi
il s'appelle magma Gordy
particulièrement symbolique pour les 9
élèves de la quatrième Gandhi leur
classe a été rebaptisée au moment où le
projet de voyage en Inde a démarré
c'est le seul personne que je sais qui a
combattu soit de violence seulement en
ballon et il y a pas beaucoup de gens
comme lui je suis content ça va aussi
son histoire son passé la flamme
éternelle continuera à brûler mais pour
marquer le coup le groupe a voulu
laisser une trace artistique dédiée à
Gandhi cette affiche créée par un
graffeur réunionnais termine son voyage
dans ce quartier de street art
la citation du chantre de la
non-violence interpelle les passants
dernière photo dernière soirée en Inde
après une courte nuit
ultime trajet en bus sur le territoire
indien les cœurs sont serrés à l'idée de
quitter cette terre de rencontres riche
en enseignement
une dizaine d'heures plus tard ce sont
d'autres larmes qui se mettent à couler
celles des parents à l'arrivée à la
Réunion dans leur bagages les collégiens
ont avant tout emporté avec eux cette
leçon de vie celle de la confrontation à
une autre culture né à 5000 km de La
Réunion et pourtant si familière des
souvenirs gravés à jamais qu'ils feront
partager à leur famille et certains
l'espère dans leur vie d'adultes à leur
propre enfant